[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous inquiétez pas ça va bien se
passer
je raconte des histoires depuis presque
20 ans ne puis presque vingt ans je me
sens lié aux racines du compte par des
hommes des femmes des compteurs des
conteuses qui depuis le grand matins du
monde génération après génération on
portait jusqu'à moi des récits des
récits qu'ils ont nourri de leur vie de
leur vécu de leur vivant parmi tous ces
récits certains me touche beaucoup
c'est comme si certains exigeaient de
moi que je les raconte alors je
m'exécute
je les raconte il était une fois un
homme et une femme
il avait de l'envié du désir l'un pour
l'autre
alors ils se sont unis réunis et c'était
bon proche de la perfection
la femme a dit qu'elle voulait cela
toujours l'un m'a dit moi aussi alors
ils ont fait ce que font les amoureux
ils se sont faits des serments d'amour
et eux ils se sont jurés et fidélité
mêmes exclusivités et cela venait de
l'homme il ne voulait pas la partager il
la voulait pour lui tout seul ne pas la
partager
même pas avec un enfant et lui a dit que
si elle venait à enfanter il la tuerait
elle a eu peur elle a eu peur de lui
elle a eu peur de ses seins qui
s'alourdissent aient peur de son ventre
qui s'arrondit c'est des fois la peur ça
donne des idées elle a eu une idée un
soir dans le silence de la presse elle a
commencé à lui raconter une histoire
lui il voulait la suite de l'histoire
le lendemain il a demandé et le jour
d'après encore et celui d'après encore
l'homme voulait connaître la fin de
l'histoire mais le bébé n'a qu' avant la
fin de l'histoire
alors elle le lui présenta dans le
berceau et lui il se sentit comme happé
par le regard noir de ce bébé
il a regardé ses petits plis ses petits
pieds molletonné sa peau douce il la
regardait elle puis l'enfant encore et
il a souri l'homme on dit que c'est
comme ça que sont nées les histoires
j'aime ce que me dit cette histoire
contée pour échapper à la mort compter
pour se soustraire à la mort c'est ce
qu'elle a fait cette femme amoureuse
elle a compris l'enjeu du compte tout
comme shéhérazade n'est ce pas elle a
utilisé les mots elle a su que les mots
lorsqu'ils sont bien tissé ont le
pouvoir magique de vous soustraire à la
mort de vous en distraire
les enfants aussi ont bien perçu ça pour
les enfants la nuit c'est comme la mort
en quelque sorte toutes les peurs
ancestrales ressortent
alors pour s'y soustraire ils nous
lancent leurs célèbres montres à papa
maman raconte moi une histoire raconte
moi une histoire
j'interviens auprès des jeunes dans les
lycées
j'arrive je me présente et je dis mon
métier de conteuse
en général les jeunes me reçoivent avec
une sorte de défiance et même un peu un
sourire goguenard les garçons surtout
ils s'asseyent plus sur leurs omoplates
que sur que sur leur séant un peu comme
ça et ils font un way conteuse
mais c'est un métier du moyen âge en
fait compte aux tueurs attend lé
conteuse la meuf elle est conteuse quoi
mais attends qui n'en est pas une
famille
[Musique]
ensuite il ya un silence et dans ce
silence j'entends leurs discours
intérieur qui doit dire en quelque sorte
allez vas-y balancela ton histoire vas-y
balance alors je m'exécute
je le raconte un père qui désirent sa
fille je leur raconte une mère qui mange
ses enfants je leur raconte un jeune qui
n'a peur de rien ni de personne et
surtout pas du croque mitaine alors il
le défie le croquemitaine le jeune il
n'aurait pas dû car le voilà transformé
en motte de beurre là sur le coin d'une
table dans la cuisine
et lorsque la mère du jeune rentre elle
voit cette tâche de graisse fondu sur le
coin de sa table
elle prend un chiffon elle est celui-là
taches de graisse et jette le chiffon au
feu je peux lire un peu des froids dans
leurs yeux parfois et j'aime bien ça
parce qu'à ce moment là je sais qu'ils
sont là avec moi dans le compte
parfois il y en a qui veulent raconter
aussi alors je les envoie chercher leur
histoire à la bibliothèque
c'est le cas de romain romain à 14 ans
et il est temps en première ce qui lui
fait deux ans d' avance c'est difficile
de gérer le groupe classe quand on a
deux ans d' avance parce que les autres
garçons vous méprise un petit peu en
fait je pense que c'est il ya une part
de jalousie parce que quand on a le
cerveau bien tourner et qu'on ira ce
mode ça plaît pas et puis les filles
elles le trouvent trop chaud romain trop
chaud trop chaud il est très chiant
romain a choisi de raconter petit à
petit au c'est un garçon tout petit os
mais qui en a là dedans et petit haut
via abu des méchants et petit haut
refuse d'épouser la belle parce qu'ils
la trouvent trop saute à mesure que
romain peaufine son histoire à mesure
qu'ils entrent dans son histoire
je sens qu'ils changent ils se
métamorphosent il se sent mieux dans le
groupe classe et un jour il nous propose
de nous raconter son histoire de bout en
bout alors nous l'écoutons romain il
parle avec aisance avec éloquence
ménages des silences il nous embarque à
la fin il ya comme un grand silence
je suis bluffé nous sommes tous bluffés
et là il ya la star de la classe qui dit
yes romain
et comme romain a été leakée par la star
de la classe c'est bon c'est bon le
compte d'ailleurs les enseignants me le
dise
depuis que l'atelier conte a commencé ça
va mieux dans la classe moins de
violence et pour cause le comte offre
des mots le comte offre une structure la
fameuse structure narrative qui permet
de se déployer dans un cadre le comte
offre des registres de langage on passe
de la solennité à la gravité à l'humour
le compte pour dire et se dire à la fin
du cycle il ya un garçon que j'aimais
bien qu'il m'a dit franchement madame le
compte ça tue trop j'espère que vous
allez revenir l'année prochaine
et moi je lui ai dit que que j'étais
ravie de son de son invitation à peine
déguisée mais je lui ai dit aussi que je
n'étais pas tout à fait d'accord avec
son point de vue pour moi le compte ne
tuait pas au contraire il est des îles
aider à guérir à nous soigner comme il
avait soigné le groupe classe qui
n'arrivait plus à dont les membres
n'arrivait plus à se parler
je raconte l'histoire d'une jeune fille
et d'un arbre qui sont amoureux et
l'arbre accepte de changer sa nature
pour épouser la jeune fille
c'est leur secret mais lorsque les
soeurs de la jeune fille
après le secret elle lui intime l'ordre
de choisir entre son amant contre nature
et sa famille son clan son village
mais comment l'on peut choisir entre ce
que l'on aime et celui que l'on aime à
la fin du spectacle de femmes viennent
me voir
l'une d'entre elles est septuagénaire
elle me dit que c'est son histoire
qu'elle vient de se rendre compte que ça
la touche et encore je raconte aussi de
la truculence des femmes avec des gros
seins des grosses fesses des paies
extraordinaire qui vous font rentrer
dans les entrailles de la terre
j'aime ça le public aussi on rit on rit
beaucoup c'est bon et à la fin du
spectacle une petite fille 7 8 ans vient
me voir une petite blonde elle me sert
fort dans ses bras elle m'embrasse et
elle me dit que son père est mort sa
mère vient me voir et elle me dit et
qu'est ce qu'elle vous a dit alors je me
répète
et là j'apprends de la bouche de la mer
que la petite fille n'a pas dit un seul
mot depuis trois mois
depuis que son père est mort le compte
ça bouscule ça bouleverse la
psychanalyse a très bien compris ça je
pense par exemple à bruno bettelheim
avec la psychanalyse des contes de fées
le conte pour soigner la psyché leconte
pour soigner le compte pour guérir le
compte serait une sorte de médicaments
une pilule
attention un médicament dont il n'y
aurait aucun effet secondaire à déplorer
pas de ces médicaments qui nous
endorment nos anesthésie au contraire ce
médicament là il nous réveille il
réveille notre jeu il nous met en
connexion avec le monde et nous
rapproche de nous mêmes
bien sûr il peut y avoir un peu
d'amertume dans ce médicament parfois
des histoires peuvent faire mal cette
amertume là elle est dissoute dans la
beauté du langage dans la poésie du
conte qui pour moi est un langage sacré
un langage qui n'a rien à voir avec
notre langage de communication de
l'ordre du passe moi le sel ou le poids
renens
ac c'est un langage qui vient du coeur
un proverbe dit que les mots qui
viennent de la bouche le touche que les
oreilles en revanche les mots qui
viennent du coeur touche le coeur des
fois je pense à cette petite fille et à
sa maman et j'imagine qu'elles vont
écouter des histoires beaucoup
d'histoires et c'est bien parce qu'elles
ont compris semble-t-il que les
histoires sont là nous ne sommes pas
seuls les histoires sont là pour pour
nous aider nous autres ce qui reste les
vivants je suis intimement persuadé que
dans toute la multitude infinie de
compte il y as pour chacune chacun
d'entre nous une histoire le tout
est de savoir quelle est la vôtre merci
[Applaudissements]